MALE SPEAKER:
Welcome, everybody,
to one more Talks
at Google event.
Today, with us is author
Abby Smith Rumsey.
She's a historian who writes
about how ideas and information
technologies shape
perceptions of history of time
and of personal and
cultural identity.
Trained at Harvard
as a Russian scholar,
she has worked in
Soviet era archives,
spent a decade at the
Library of Congress,
and has consulted on digital
collecting and curation,
intellectual property
issues, and the economics
of digital information for
universities and the National
Science Foundation.
Abby will be talking
today about what
it means to preserve
digital artifacts
and non-digital artifacts,
data storage is not memory,
forgetting is the first
step in remembering,
and memory is not the past,
it's about the future.
So for us, it's
probably relevant
that the average web
page lasts 100 days.
Ease of online
access dupes people
into a false sense of
security that information,
our information, will be equally
accessible in the future.
There's many more
things on this topic,
and I welcome Abby,
today, to Google.
This is the book,
which is in print now.
And please welcome
Abby to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY:
Thank you very much.
I'm delighted to be here.
I will be talking
about memory, and why
preserving digital
information is important.
Not because it's about the past,
but it is about the future.
And that's the main
contention of the talk, which
is that it's actually
from the past
that we manufacture the future.
Which I think is a
particularly relevant topic
for people who are in
the midst of building
digital technologies, which
in fact are not secure.
We don't know how to
secure them for future use.
But I'd like to
begin this talk, if I
may, with lines
from a local poet,
written in Berkeley in 1986.
And it goes like
this, the last stanza.
I imagine the Earth
when I am no more.
Nothing happens, no loss.
It's still a strange pageant.
Women's dresses, dewy
lilacs, a song in the valley.
And yet the books will be there
on the shelves, well-born,
derived from people, but also
from radiance, from heights.
That's, of course,
a poetic vision
of how memory lasts
through physical artifacts.
And those are the words
of Czeslaw Milosz,
who won the Nobel Prize
for Literature in 1980.
He called himself
a poet of memory
for very compelling reasons.
He lived in Berkeley for
decades as a political exile
from his native Poland, and
for almost all of his life
as a linguistic exile from
his native language of Polish.
He had a long and eventful life,
full of great discontinuities,
many of them forced on him by
political regimes he did not
agree with, and some of them
he chose because of the path
that he chose as a poet.
But through all those years,
nine decades and more,
he relied on memory
to create a sense
of meaning in an
autobiographical narrative.
And I think his life is
very instructive in a time
when cultural change is so
rapid that even the landscapes
that we know are
changing and will
be obsolete by the
time you're grown up.
The landscapes, the physical
landscapes you know,
will be gone.
And how will you remember
what those landscapes were,
not to mention the sort
of knowledge landscapes
that you grew up in?
So I just want to give
you a sense of my priors,
a sort of perspective I
have on this as a historian.
Because I rely on memory
too, the traces and written
records that people
leave behind.
Historians call this evidence.
You'll call this data, but we're
talking about the same thing.
And it was in 1997,
almost 20 years ago,
that I first began
to think seriously
about what would happen
to all the evidence that
then existed on durable
artifacts, textual, visual,
and oral.
How will that knowledge
survive in the digital age,
and what will be the new
forms of instantiation
of knowledge for those formats?
So what will happen when,
for example, this technology
replaces this technology?
What will be around in
100 years or 500 years?
This book has a
really good chance
of lasting all that time.
What about this?
And this isn't just
a telephone or books.
This is almost all of
my life is on this,
all of my personal data, and
a lot of copyrighted data,
and public data as well.
So it's a very complex issue.
So I wrote this
book first in order
to answer the
question for myself.
So as an historian, it
seems self-evident, to me,
actually, that everything
and everyone that exists
has a backstory.
And it's the backstory
that tells us who we are,
and not only that, who we
are capable of becoming.
Now, I spent my
formative years, as Bohr
said, doing a
doctoral dissertation
and research in the
Soviet Union in the 1980s.
At that time, I
learned something
that I never would have
imagined as an American citizen,
particularly one going to
a very good school that
had a library that was
always open almost 24/7.
And that is that I was
routinely denied documents
that dated back to the 1680s.
And I was, in fact, told
that they didn't exist,
although I was able to
consult copies of them
back at Weiner
Library at Harvard.
My Soviet friends,
of course, when
I would complain to them
about this, would laugh.
And they would say, come on.
You know, in this country it's
the future that is certain.
It will be a utopia.
It's the past that
is always changing.
And that's when I
began to realize that,
in fact, when you control
someone's understanding
of the past, you
control their sense
of who they are and also
their sense of what they
can imagine becoming.
So backstories I learned that
way are very powerful, and very
fragile, and always at risk.
What we know about
ourselves, that
is what we're allowed
to know about ourselves
and what we're not allowed
is, in fact, a fundamental
component of our freedom
and our autonomy.
So actually, I care
about the future
of our collective memory.
And I'm alarmed to
think that we don't
have a way of
securing it, really
I think in 2016 it's
different than 1997.
At that time, nobody seemed
to understand this problem
except a couple of librarians
and archivists, honestly.
And now in 2016, if
we just look at what's
happening on campuses
not just in this country
but across the
world, we understand
that people are
growing up demanding
that they get to know
their own history,
and they get to tell
their own history
so that whose history
gets told and by whom
is fundamental to human
rights and human autonomy
as freedom is to
choose government.
And that's why I
wrote what is really
a little book about
a very big idea.
And today, I just
want to give you
a sense of some of the topics
that I cover in the book
that I think will be of
most interest to you,
at least I imagine.
Although I may be wrong,
in fact, about what's
most interesting to people
in the technology world.
So I want to start, if I
may, with a fairly well-known
document.
This document is, obviously,
the Declaration of Independence.
When I was working at the
Library of Congress in 1997,
we put together an exhibition
of the library's treasures.
And among the
greatest treasures,
including the first couple
drafts of the Gettysburg
Address in Lincoln's
hand, is this draft
of the Declaration of
Independence, written by Thomas
Jefferson in his hand.
He was 33 years old
at the time, and he
was tasked to come
up with a draft
that he would hand off
to John Adams and Ben
Franklin, who would then
edit it and send it forward.
So when we put this on
display, people would always
appear and look for
the famous words,
"we hold these truths
to be self-evident
that all men are created equal."
But that's not actually
what Jefferson wrote.
He wrote something different.
He wrote that "these truths
are sacred and undeniable."
The words that we
know now are actually
a correction by Ben Franklin.
So the whole document,
all four pages,
is like this-- very
heavily edited.
And it's very
interesting to compare
what Jefferson saw as
the Declaration of Rights
and what became approvable
by other people, approved
by other people.
And the thing that was
interesting for tourists
was that at that time
through this artifact
they could see not just
what the process of editing
was and the evolution of
thinking in the debate that
went on, but this
artifact actually
reflects evolution of thinking
and the process of democracy
itself.
As an artifact, you
can see the arguments
that took place and the
compromises that were reached.
Although to be
fair, Ben Franklin
did usually get his way.
After all, he was much older
and thought himself much wiser.
But in 1997, again, only
people in the library
and in the archives
actually seemed
to understand what was at risk.
We already knew that the
archives, the National
Archives, which is
charged with keeping
the records of the
government and making them
accessible to the people,
they were, in fact,
being inundated by emails coming
off of Bill Clinton's server.
I should say, I don't
really mean server.
They were actually
arriving in floppy disks,
if you can believe it or not.
And people didn't
really know how
to sort them, let alone preserve
them and figure out what there
was that needed to be saved.
So this is the
fundamental problem.
We have an
infrastructure in place,
perfected over, really,
centuries and millennia
for preserving knowledge by
preserving physical artifacts.
We do manage our knowledge by
managing physical artifacts.
And this doesn't
work for us anymore.
Now we have to
manage our knowledge
by managing electrical grids,
codes, hardware, software,
many of which is proprietary.
And all of it is very
fragile and dependent
upon a secure flow of
energy, which, of course, is
a very contested issue.
What we don't have is the
advantage of durability.
And this is a cuneiform, as
many of you may recognize.
This tablet is 2,700 years old.
There's no chance that
digital informational
will live for 2,700
years and be like this,
completely i-legible.
I'm slightly kidding
when I say i-legible.
You do have to be able to read
Akkadian to know what it says.
But anybody who
can learn Akkadian
can understand what this is.
This is, in fact, about
how to divine omens.
It's a divination tablet.
Omens, how to read the birth
defects of humans and animals
to tell the fortune
of the people who
are seeking their fortune.
You know, the interesting
thing about these clay tablets
is that they're the
longest enduring
evidence we have of humans
outsourcing their knowledge
on to physical objects.
And unlike all other forms that
were invented from papyrus on,
when these things go
and are set in flames,
they actually don't perish.
They actually get harder.
As any of you know
who have worked clay,
firing makes it very hard.
So you can say that,
actually, digital technology
is the latest instantiation,
but all preservation has
gone downhill from here.
We can save a lot more.
And we can cram in a
lot more information.
But with each degree
of information,
we lose a significant
degree of durability.
The thing that's perplexing,
I think, for most people
is that we have
these systems set
in place to answer the question,
what can we afford to save?
Because the cost of committing
information to a durable form
has always been very high.
The upfront costs
have been very high.
Even getting a
book in print, you
have to go through
many different
what I think of as filters.
It's not just the
author writing.
You also have to get an agent to
sell the book to the publisher.
The publisher then has to find a
way to publish it and market it
in the marketplace.
And then libraries
acquire them--
they don't acquire
all books-- so
that you have some chance that
something significant will
last.
And now the question for us
is what can we afford to lose?
Now that there are
actually no filters
to creating information
or using information,
it proliferates quite
promiscuously on the web
and in other forms and other
places besides the web.
And it all looks about the same.
It's all on the same format,
this electrical code,
and it's hard to place
value on it the way
you would just by looking at
a book or a film, for example.
And hardest of all,
for most people,
is that people will not be
making the decisions about what
gets saved.
Machines will be.
That is, the machines that
people make and program.
But for most people,
the idea that machines
are what's going to read
all this information
and make decisions
about what gets saved
is actually quite formidable.
I think it is a formidable
task because machines can't
save any of this information.
We're not sure that it's very
secure or readable over time.
So we're at this
particular juncture in time
when we're going from one
old technology, one memory
technology, to a new.
And I would argue that although
we've done this before,
the quality of change is
actually quite different
in this case, because
of issues of electricity
and non-i-legibility
of some of the formats.
But as I said, we've gone
through this change before.
I won't recapitulate
this, but in the book,
I talk about these
moments of change
and what's at risk to
our cultural memory
by using this shorthand model
of cultural change, which
I think of as the
push-me, pull-you moment.
Now, some of you may
recognize this creature.
Maybe you don't.
It was invented or first
spotted, I should say,
in 1923 by Hugh
Lofting, who wrote
a book called "The
Adventures of Dr. Doolittle."
Dr. Doolittle was
an animal doctor
who went to Africa, of course, a
fictional character, and found,
hunted down, this long
extinct, thought to be extinct,
animal, the rarest creature
of all, the push-me, pull-you,
that had two heads--
a gazelle on one end
and a unicorn on the other.
And although they could agree
on most divisions of labor,
for example, what one would
eat and the other would talk.
So someone could always
be eating and talking
without anybody being rude.
They had a very hard
time whenever anyone told
them to do something quickly.
Because they had to consult,
and they often didn't agree.
And if they didn't agree, if
they completely disagreed,
then they would
actually be paralyzed.
But if they kind of
agreed but couldn't
agree how to leave room,
for example, then they
would move sideways,
and they would end up
in a very unexpected
place, even though they
thought they had agreed
on where they were going.
And the faster they moved,
the more unpredictable
the resulting end was.
This is a very common feature
in these inflection points
in memory technology change,
say in the cuneiform time
and also when papyri
were invented.
Certainly during the
printed revolution,
which I'll talk a little
bit about as time permits.
But it's pretty reliable,
according to this theory
and according to real life, that
whenever there's a new memory
technology that comes along,
memory being so personal,
it's seen by some as
creative and very exciting.
And it's seen by many
others and condemned
as disruptive and destructive.
And rather than giving you
a lot of piquant examples
from history, I'll just go to
the granddaddy of curmudgeons,
Socrates, and tell
you what he thought
about the invention of writing.
Because he thought
that it would lead
to ignorance and ultimately
to the death of memory itself.
And this is what he said.
He said, "for this
invention will produce
forgetfulness in the minds
of those who learn to use it,
because they will not
practice their memory.
Their trust in writing produced
by external characters which
are no part of themselves
will discourage
the use of their own
memory within them.
You have invented an elixir
not of memory but of reminding.
And you offer your pupils
not the appearance of wisdom,
nor true wisdom.
For they will read many
things without instruction,
and will therefore seem
to know many things when
they are for the most
part ignorant and hard
to get along with,
since they are not wise
but only appear wise."
Now, there are many complaints
about what the new memory
technologies do for knowledge
in this current environment,
but I think Socrates
got it dead wrong.
Because those societies that
didn't adopt are writing,
in fact, went
extinct very quickly.
And they were made
extinct by cultures
that did carry writing with
them, which was rapidly
adopted by other cultures.
Furthermore, as I think Socrates
must have known himself,
that if Plato hadn't been
writing down every single word
he'd said that nobody would know
that Socrates had ever existed.
And thus the problem
with vanishing knowledge.
There are many
things that we think
Socrates said and
were written down
by Plato that
actually did vanish
when the Library of
Alexandria vanished, we think.
So I won't go into
the inflection points
that I talk about in
the book, but I just
want to note for your interest
that among the first people who
show up as early adopters of
a memory technology, and this
is well documented
during the print
revolution of the 15th
and 16th centuries,
there are two
categories you can make
sure will show up right away.
The first are pornographers,
and the second
are ideological
fanatics and terrorists.
This was certainly true
during the Reformation,
when print was adopted far more
rapidly and deftly by people
we now, in retrospect, call
Protestants, people who
were protesting against
the power of the pope,
than by the Catholic Church
itself, which had as much power
to defend its hegemony
over the world of ideas.
But somehow because they were
slower at mastering print,
they didn't get as much
traction as the Protestants.
And believe it or not,
at that time, of course,
people believed that because it
was in print it had to be true.
And that was one way
that some of the most
fanatic of the Protestant
sectarians got their way.
And there's a lesson in
here-- I won't draw it out
for you-- about what's going on
today with religious terrorism
of all sorts and ideological
terrorism throughout the world.
Technology is only a tool.
It depends upon who picks
it up as to what its use is.
So I want to talk a
little bit about-- history
tells us, OK, we've
been here before.
And some of the
things that we are
seeing in this period of
transition we've seen before.
It's a temporary
phase, but it's also
one in which a lot is at risk.
I want to talk just
briefly again about what
science tells us about
these periods of transition
and about memory.
So I say, as Bohr said, that
memory is not about the past.
It's actually about the future.
Why do we have this idea,
and how is it that science
buttresses this idea?
Well, first of all, we know that
memory is ubiquitous in nature,
because, in fact, all
matter is information.
Memory is nature's
go-to solution
for the challenges of adaptation
to changing environments.
From the amoeba to
the zebra, everybody
has a certain amount of
preprogrammed memory,
this strand we call DNA.
But every creature
is born having
to learn its environment.
And so nature created this thing
called memory, called learning.
And when that creature
dies, everything it learned
dies with it, except for human
beings, and some creatures
that create culture and can
pass things along culturally.
But if you see that creature up
there in the corner, of course,
above the volcano,
that's actually
a dodo that was extinct when
this book was done in 1841.
Actually, a notation says that
the last dodo was seen in 1691.
And that's what happens
when a creature can't
adapt very quickly to
a changing environment.
It becomes extinct.
Just think a thought experiment
about how much memory means.
So imagine waking
up in the morning
and not knowing
where you are, not
knowing what the room is, not
knowing where you came from
or how you ended up there, not
having any idea what you're
supposed to do now that you
see yourself in your body,
and certainly not knowing who
you were, and not knowing what
your name is, because
you didn't know there
were such things as names.
In other words,
no memory, no you.
That's the sum of
what memory is.
So the brain has an
incredibly big job to do.
It's basically
trying to sort out,
in this data deluge it's
in 24/7 all the time,
what's important for
survival and what isn't.
And that's the
ultimate criterion
for what the brain
sorts through.
So what's valuable in the short
term is anything that's new.
We pay attention
to all the things
that are new, that the
brain has never seen before.
And this is one of the keys
that people on Madison Avenue
learned a long time
ago in the period
of "Mad Men," for
example, that the way you
get people's attention
is by flashing something
new or colorful in front of
them to get their attention.
Pay attention.
The brain does pay
attention to those cues.
But it throws most of
that information away,
and it only keeps that
which is valuable.
So what is valuable
over the long term
from an animal's point of view?
Information is
valuable to the extent
that it has potential for reuse.
And this is the main
lesson, I think,
that science can teach us now
in this period of information
abundance in which
we are effectively,
our cultural institutions,
our cultural memories
are in the same
position, the same bind,
as the human brain is, that
only those things which
can be reused should be saved.
But the truth is, that's exactly
what librarians and archivists
do now.
They think very much about
what's possible for reuse.
And so they would just
assume keep everything,
and they can't because of
the physical constraints.
Now they can't keep
everything in digital form,
because they can't keep
up with the volume.
And this is something that I
think technologies companies,
really, are best
positioned to solve,
how to keep a lot
of data secure,
even at low levels
of curation to be
available to be looked at in
20, 30, 50 years to determine
its long term value.
I want to point out one of
the things about this image
that's so remarkable
and that I think
few people in the information
industry understand.
It's the kind of Genesis
moment of their own work.
And that is this
incredible discovery
made at the end of the
18th, early 19th century,
that the world is, in fact,
very old and knows everything.
The technologically
advanced data
rich world we live in today all
devolves from that central one
discovery, that the universe
was created in deep time,
extends infinitely
across deep space,
and leaves a record of
its own history in matter.
So the material universe
is itself in archives,
and the Earth writes its
own autobiography in matter.
In other words, rocks or clocks.
This is what
geologists discovered
at the end of the 18th century.
And this leads up, of course,
to the embrace of materialism,
scientific materialism, the
idea that the universe and all
that exists is no
more and no less
than the material effect
of material causes.
So just to be clear,
technologies always
arise out of a demand.
And materialism itself began
this really escalating demand
for more information,
finer data about the world,
itsy bitsy pieces of matter.
In fact, until we get to
the Large Hadron Collider
and beyond, we want
more and more data,
because that's how
we know the world.
Technologies appear, as
I say, out of demand,
and just to give you an example,
this is the Gutenberg Bible.
And the Gutenberg
Bible wasn't invented
because people wanted a brand
new way of reading the Bible.
In fact, what they wanted
was, they wanted this.
They wanted a handwritten Bible.
This is a giant Bible of Mainz.
These are both at the Library
of Congress, incidentally.
They were both done in the
1450s in Mainz, the same town.
And one, this one, was designed
to look exactly like this one.
Because people don't want
new newfangled things.
What they were looking for
were old newfangled things,
only cheaper.
And I think that explains a lot
of the initial phases of web
design.
Why do we call web
pages pages after all?
So this period of time
in the 1830s, 1840s
saw an incredible change in
the culture of all of us,
in fact, our
fascination with data,
and gave birth to this
kind of forensic hunt
for evidence which
has ultimately
led to the introduction of
computers into our lives
and our demand for big data.
It also invented, of course, Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle's character
Sherlock Holmes.
I mean, the grand narrative of
our age is whodunit and how?
And that's all a riff
on materialism, that is,
trying to understand the
world through the traces,
the evidence, of
what it used to be.
The collective memory that have
has made us a unique species.
And all it's taken
are four things.
And the first is these
empirical methods
that derive from
materialist theories,
the second is the harnessing
by economic systems
to apply that knowledge
and create ever
finer instruments to accumulate
ever greater amounts of data.
Also, dedicated resources to
educate an expert workforce,
and the fourth, and perhaps
the most contested right now,
are political regimes that
keep the pursuit of knowledge
well resourced and protected
from ideological interference.
Without any one of those,
then the entire enterprise
of science and technology is
threatened and could collapse.
So here we are, a species that's
uniquely strong and uniquely
dominant over the planet
because of the power of culture
and knowledge that
builds on knowledge.
So what could go wrong?
Well, actually a lot, and
I want to talk briefly
about some of the things
that go wrong with memory.
I'm going to use some
personal case studies.
Memory science has made
extraordinary advances
in studying memory
in healthy people
by looking at what happens when
memory degenerates or is flawed
in people who suffer
from memory disorders.
And the two lessons, the two
cases I'm going to look at,
tell us a lot about
some of the threats
for our collective memory
in the digital age.
The first thing we
need to think about
is the importance of forgetting.
This is a picture of
a doctor, Dr. Luria,
who had a patient well
known in memory science,
a patient called S. His
real name was Shereshevskii,
but I'm going to call him S.
He, like Luria, lived in
Russia in Soviet times.
And Luria was his doctor.
S had a disorder that
Luria very elegantly
called "he lacked the
art of forgetting."
In fact, he was a man
who had what we would
call a photographic memory.
He could remember everything.
And although it sounds
actually quite envious,
I know many people think, wow.
I wish I had that
kind of memory.
In fact, the art of forgetting
is the faculty simply
of being able to sort long
term or short term memories
and consolidating them
into long term memories
and basically getting
rid of the rest.
Remember, the way
the brain works
is in fact to sort out what's
valuable and keeping it.
And that's what it does
every night during sleep,
for example.
Just in case you wonder
why we need sleep,
one of the many
reasons we need sleep
is because the brain actually
sorts through short term
memories and begins the
process of converting them
into long term memories, if
they're meant to be around.
And then it basically
throws out the rest.
So basically the
brain is in there,
taking out the
trash every night.
And if you don't
get enough sleep,
that trash hangs around
inside of your brain
and mucks it up for a long time.
So you need sleep to
have a good memory,
and in fact, to have a
well-balanced sense of living.
Because what
happened to this man,
although he made a good living
as a mnemonist for a while,
as a memory artist.
He was actually quite
miserable in his personal life.
He was really unable
to sort out what
was important from unimportant.
And he was unable, literally,
to put together a narrative,
because he couldn't
understand what was important.
Because he couldn't understand
the value of anything,
he actually had no sense
of cause and effect,
how life happened.
So he went through life
as a kind of dream,
not really figuring
out what was going on,
and never being able to keep
a job, because he didn't
have a plan for anything.
And this is what he says.
At one point, I studied
the stock market.
And when I showed that I
had a good memory for prices
on the exchange,
I became a broker.
But it was just something I did
for a while to make a living.
As for real life, that
was something else again.
It all took place in
dreams, not in reality.
And he talks,
actually, at length.
He's quoted by Luria at
length poignantly about how
he kept groping for things
to actually click in and make
sense for him, but he
just couldn't understand
how things really worked.
And Luria poignantly says,
and here I quote his doctor,
"that he had a family, a
fine wife, and a son, who
was a success, but this too he
perceived as through a haze.
Indeed, one would
be hard put to say
which was more real for him, the
world of imagination in which
he lived, or the world
of reality, in which he
was but a temporary guest."
So remember that forgetting
is really important.
And you don't need to
think about forgetting.
Your brain does
it automatically.
And one of the things that
we should be thinking about,
or I would like
people to think about,
is when we teach
our machines how
to sort through all the
incoming information of a day,
how to search for value,
that pattern matching
with what is determined to
be value is really important,
and that the processes need to
be carried on in individuals
largely unconsciously
we can't think
about them too consciously.
So this is my image of what
it was like when S would
go try to retrieve a memory.
In fact, it was
like he was walking
into this crowded hall, where
all this stuff was unsorted.
And he would trip
over one thing,
and it would immediately
trigger so many memories
that he would literally go
off in some other direction
and forget why he had come
into his memory palace
to find something.
So forgetting is very
important, but of course,
forgetting too much is
desperately horrible.
And here, I talk at some
length about the case
of Alzheimer's patients,
in this case Iris Murdoch,
a very prolific writer and
philosopher, who succumbed
Alzheimer's later in her life.
And we know a lot
about what it meant,
because her husband,
John Bailey,
wrote a very moving
memoir of his wife
as he watched her basically
disintegrate in front
of his eyes.
He describes her losing
her sense of self,
her sense of direction,
of course, her memory,
but essentially her
personality, her Iris-ness.
And what was most remarkable was
that she lost her imagination.
If you know Iris
Murdoch's work, you
know that she was
fantastically imaginative.
She wrote prolifically.
And everything gave her an idea
for a whole fantastic novel
or a philosophical speculation.
And this was lost to her
because without a past,
she had no imagination.
And that's why I say that memory
really isn't about the past.
It's actually the raw
material of the future.
And this is well documented
in neuroscientific literature.
Imagination actually is
memory in the future tense.
The true value of the past is
that it is the raw material
we use to create the future.
And so the greater our
collective memory, ,
the collective memory from
the very beginning of time,
the greater the resources
for our imagination.
Think of it as a very
expansive mental toolkit
for solving near term
and long term problems.
So what now, if the real
problem we're facing now
is that we don't
know how to secure
a lot of the past
for the future,
and we agree that
preserving and making
the past, a record of the past
accessible for the future,
is how we're going to
move into the future?
So what do we do now?
How do we actually move from
this world, this instantiation
of knowledge,
which was perfected
over millennia, into a world
that looks like this, In fact?
Let me just stop, if I
may, to go back and talk
about how at the time
this building, which
was opened in 1850,
it's by Henri Labrouste.
It was a revolutionary
building very
influenced by the political
revolutions of 1848.
And it was vaunting
this brand new--
and it was very high tech.
It was built with cast iron,
and it had a very large windows
to let in a lot of light.
And because it was
built out of cast iron,
it was actually a kind of
natural fire retardant.
And furthermore, it
was for students.
Students didn't have
such a big space before.
They would have to
study in their rooms.
See, this embodies
these democratic ideals
of study and access.
They kept this open long hours.
So the question is,
how do we not only
move that legacy
into this, but also
how do we aestheticize the
experience of knowledge,
the way knowledge has been
aestheticized over the past
and made it really attractive?
I want to briefly talk
about the three things
that we need to
do now, and sooner
rather than later, in order to
achieve this kind of nirvana
of a world in which
we have access
to the full, rich memory
of the human past.
First is to take all
of the legacy work
that's on physical formats now
and convert it to digital form.
And what you see
here is a picture
of what I think of
as a local hero.
Carl Haber, who works up at
the Lawrence Berkeley Lab,
an experimental
physicist by day.
And when he was building some
of the imaging techniques
he used in the Large
Hadron Collider
to look for traces
of the Higgs-Boson,
he realized that the
imaging technology
they were creating
in the lab would
be good for imaging very
fragile analog recorded
sound formats that were not
capable of being played back.
I'm sure you know that every
time you play an analog record
back or a wax cylinder, that
the information layer actually
physically degrades.
So people in audio preservation
don't play anything back.
They want this sort of
non-contact playback.
And he's able to
take this technology
and recreate things
that were incalculable.
No one ever thought
they're hear.
You can see on the screen
those tracks behind
him are actually a pictorial.
Well, they're
visualizations of sound.
So the sound is converted to
digital format, digital images,
and then you can play it back.
So we have an amazing
array of technologies now
that can extract extraordinary
information from analog.
And I just want to point
out that in this day of you
know genetic research,
forensic research, in fact,
that all those things,
the natural history
museums with their
drawers full of specimens,
and bugs and things,
and stuffed birds,
they're actually the Fort Knox
of the genetic research world.
They're the things
that hold specimens
of things already extinct
or unfortunately about
to become extinct.
So we need to remediate
those analog format materials
onto digital form as quickly
as we can at the same time we
preserve the original.
The other thing we
need to do is to start
taking care of digital content.
And here's another
local boy, Brewster
[? Kale, ?] who allows
people using the web
to upload their own
content in an open format
to be preserved on
the internet Archive
and accessible as long as the
Internet Archive is on board,
and presumably, the
Archives' materials
will move to another
long term preservation
institution over time.
What Brewster is able to
do, and what we should all
be thinking about,
especially companies
that own a lot of data, like
Twitter, for example, that
really maintain control
over it for now,
is to think about
developing a partnership
between that company
and a long term
preserving institution,
something public,
and handing over the
legacy of their materials
when they no longer want it
to a long term institution
for preservation purposes.
The other thing that
I think about when
I see the Internet Archive is
the answer to the question,
so how do we know what's
going to be of value?
How do we know that?
We can't actually put
digital content on a shelf
and know that it's going
to be there in 500 years,
and someone's going
to come along and make
a decision about whether it
was important now or not.
The thing is, we need to save
as much as we can, as I said,
but we need to start
each of us with saving
the thing that is of value to
ourselves and make that easy.
I say as an historian who worked
with a very limited source
base, there's not much that
survives from 17th century
Muscovy.
And not much of it
records information
that I want to know
about, which had
nothing to do with, say,
liturgical matters or court
rolls.
Nonetheless, what information
was available was very useful.
So save whatever you can.
Save mostly what is
important to you.
And finally, I want
to talk about the last
and I think possibly the
most important invisible risk
to our cultural heritage.
And that is, it's more
of a mindset, I'd say.
It's one that makes us prone
to creating a knowledge
monoculture, what I think
is a knowledge monoculture.
The idea prevalent
today that there
is such a thing
as progress, which
renders knowledge obsolete.
This is particularly true
in science and engineering,
where the idea that
new discoveries
actually make other
things obsolete.
Well, they make them not very
relevant in the near term,
but there isn't any piece
of cultural information,
cultural learning, which is
truly obsolete in the sense
that we can flush it
away, because, in fact, we
know from our friend biologists
that there are lots of things
that animals carry around, their
useless limbs that are never
used, for example, that
when environments change,
they can use that useless
limb, that thing, that fin,
they can use it they and turn
this kind of maladaptation
into what we call an
exaptation, turning it
into something that can be
useful in a new environment.
You know that mammals didn't
evolve legs to walk on land.
They were able to walk on land
because they had something
that could evolve into legs.
And I think that particularly
given how much we ourselves,
our species, is
radically changing
the natural environment,
we need to actually
be scrupulous in keeping
as much information
about that environment and
about how indigenous peoples
understood that environment.
Whether it's scientific
understanding
or not, we can't afford
to flush knowledge away,
because we don't
know what we're going
to need when the world changes
as it is changing very rapidly.
So I want to leave
you with this,
what I think of as a sort
of paleolithic selfie.
This actually survives in
the Chauvet Cave in France.
It's dated probably to
35, 40,000 years ago.
And truthfully, we know
it was made about then.
And we know those
are human hands,
but we don't know what
they're trying to tell us.
We do know that they
are human beings,
and that they wanted to leave
their mark on the world.
We are such an amazing species.
It's flabbergasting to
think about the fact
that we not only have
the kind of memory
that we can share
amongst each other,
but that our entire worlds,
even my personal mental model
of the world, has been hugely
expanded because of the access
I have to everybody
else's collective memory.
This potential to learn and
to incorporate the world
through the learning of others--
it was a wonderful thing when
we had books and people
had access to libraries.
But now that we
have the internet,
it's almost
incalculable the amount
of information, and knowledge,
and ways of understanding
what it means to be
human that we can absorb.
So what is at stake
now in human memory
is keeping all of that
knowledge intact and accessible
for the long term, especially
keeping the most diverse
and maybe unedifying
aspects of it,
the most backward aspects
of it, because that too
is part of learning what
it is to be a human being
and to be humane to each other.
So I think that we
can certainly develop
skills to manage and
take responsibility
for digital memory
that outlives us
in a way like books,
derived from people
but also from radiant heights.
But now it's up to us to
figure out how to do it.
And the future, in that
sense, as well as the past,
is in our hands.
So I thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'd be happy to
take any questions.
AUDIENCE: Fascinating subject.
Actually, when I was in college,
I worked for a little while
at ibiblio, the archive at UNC,
and had a lot of conversations
on subjects like this.
One of the things that we
were working on at the time
was a system based
on BitTorrent.
And you touched on
this distributed method
of preserving information
briefly when you said,
we should all decide what
we individually value
and save that.
And I'd love to hear
more of your thoughts.
Clearly we have this
idea in large libraries
and archives of we want the
copy of something, maybe,
and we want to preserve it in
as durable a format as possible.
But on the other hand,
now with the internet,
with digital information
that's so readily copied,
there's this other
mechanism, maybe
this more like direct
democracy, anarchic mechanism
of just everybody who
wants it, copies it,
and they put it on the internet,
or they torrent it or whatever,
and make it available that way.
Do you think there
is necessarily
a tension between
those two impulses?
Do they go do they go together?
Is it something that you
see in the future maybe
one overwhelming the other?
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: It's
an excellent question,
and of course, as
you probably know
by asking when you were
framing the question,
there is actually no particular
answer to that question.
I think the model of push-me,
pull-you is pretty good.
It's both end.
We want both end.
But you're right, especially
in the short term,
with the amount of redundant
information that circulates.
And that's just on the web.
There's a lot of
information on what
used to be called the dark
web, which is even greater,
which is redundant.
We really don't want to shut
down our systems by having
too much redundant information.
I didn't go into
this, but I think
that there are a lot of
the problems that we face
that appear to be
conceptual that
are in fact quite solvable if
we apply technical minds to it.
I think the challenge
that I've seen
is that the conceptual models
haven't been worked out.
I mean, I'm really
quite confident
that any difficult
problem that I
can imagine in the universe
of information in the future,
there is a technical
solution for.
And one of the things
that is really on me
and most people who think about
these issues at a larger scale
is to formulate those
challenges in a way that
actually make them actionable.
I won't say programmable,
but at least understandable.
How do we actually
develop, let's call it,
a program to sort through that?
We're actually still stuck
in this library model
that we fix a version
to a physical object.
And that's a very sloppy
way of actually saying
that we take one version.
In the old days, the
libraries of record
would collect one copy
of a newspaper every day.
And there was something the
New York Times produced called
the official copy of the day.
This problem disappeared
during the first Iraq War,
when CNN became something
that was updating news 24/7.
Television audio,
television archivists
have known this problem from
the beginning of archival time,
actually.
They have developed
things, kinds of sampling.
So we have a lot to learn about
sampling of real time data.
I also think that's an issue
that the GIS communities
thought a lot about.
We have a lot of real
time data, and not
just from satellite data but
about water, sewage, and things
like that, all of which is in
these very dynamic systems,
geographic information systems.
They also need to think
about intelligent ways
of sampling the information.
They don't want to keep it all.
Astronomers,
unfortunately, also face
this problem, because every
day is a new day in space.
Every day is a new day in space.
It's history.
As to what BitTorrent
and individual action
has to do with this, I expanded
the problem to a larger one,
but to get back to
individuals, I just
want to say that when we were
working on the National Science
Foundation Blue
Ribbon Task Force
on the economics of
digital archiving,
economists were really
frustrated, because we,
the historians and
archivists and librarians,
couldn't concretize for
them what the long term
value of information was.
And it was very hard
for them to come up
with an economic model for
this in the capitalist market
system.
They had to rely on public
goods models, which are greatly
disadvantaged in this
country right now.
And the best we
could come up with
was these partnerships
between private companies
that control a
lot of information
and public institutions
for the long term.
I point to the Internet
Archive as an example.
Unfortunately, it's
one of the few examples
of a scalable archive that is
open to the public in general,
not just to researchers in
a research library world.
But I think that all I can
offer is the short term
solution, which is to
keep as much as possible,
and to identify what
is valuable for you,
and make it clear that
we need to develop,
need to be developing now,
computer intelligence that
will be able to
dedupe, that is get
rid of duplicate information
the way librarians
and archivists actually
get rid of duplicate copies
in their collections.
I mean, all of the
practices there
are now from the
archival world need
to be ported into
the digital world.
I actually don't think that
will be that challenging.
The challenging part is
the human engineering.
So how do you get people
from old memory institutions
and that model to sit down
with people from a new world,
make them aware of the
problem, get them interested,
and then come up with
shared solutions?
I've spent much of
the past 20 years
in rooms with people
who've been talking
past each other
about this issue.
And I'm very hopeful
that it's not going
to be an issue for much longer.
I will say as an addendum, and
it's a very important addendum,
a lot of the things which are
a stopping progress right now,
regrettably, have nothing
to do with either technology
or concept, and they
have purely to do
with political
information policy.
So we really have issues
around privacy and security
about copyright
ownership and access
of data, issues
that are unresolved,
haven't gone to court.
They're not updated.
The copyright law hasn't really
been appropriately updated
for the digital age.
And until we solve
those policy issues,
we're just going to be stopped
dead in our tracks, actually.
Once we solve those, I
think a lot of these issues
will actually-- I won't say
they'll solve themselves,
but the explosion in innovation
in digital practice, people
feeling free because
they now know
what rights they have
in their own data
and the responsibilities
that they have
to take care of their
data, because no one else
is going to take
care of it for them,
this is really going
to be a huge change.
And I think people who are
in their 20s and 30s who
understand the issue
now will be living
through an extraordinary
period of creativity
in another decade, as they
themselves apply themselves
to solving some
of these problems.
That doesn't really answer
all of your question,
but it points to a direction.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
So it seems like for the
bulk of human history,
knowledge was passed on
through oral tradition
and watching people do stuff
and learning from example.
And then we started
writing things down.
And we did that for
a few millennia.
And now we don't write it down.
We type it in.
And so it exists
more ephemerally.
A bit similar to
the oral tradition,
except it's now,
instead of being stored
in a human mind, which lasts
only a few decades, it's stored
in computer systems, which can
last as long as we really want
them to, as long as we care
to maintain it, and migrate
the formats and so forth.
So it seems like a third age
is being entered at this point.
And you know, I
just wonder what we
can learn from the previous
two to keep that going.
Or how many of the rules
that worked in the second age
need to apply in the
third age, so to speak?
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: It's
an excellent question,
and I agree with you.
It is a fundamentally
different age.
And I certainly know
about anthropologists
and paleontologists who
believe, in fact, we're
becoming a totally
different kind of animal
because of this technology
and the way that we cooperate.
I am very fond of this
image, in particular,
because I think of this as
the first concrete evidence,
no pun intended, that humans are
distinct because, in fact, they
did figure out how
to cheat death.
I really don't know
whether they decided
to invent writing that
outlived to them when
they began to realize that
they were mortal or vice versa.
But it is through our
culture, and especially
our concrete, concretized
physical culture,
that we are capable
of cheating death.
And that's a major investment
that we need to keep going.
We are returning to many of
the most wonderful aspects
of oral culture, including the
sharing and the sociability
of the most social
animals on the planet
that was lost to a large
extent in the writing world.
Writing is vaunted
now-- or a book
I should say-- it's
vaunted as having
a very singular and solitary
experience, which is true.
But it's actually
not solitary at all.
You're reading the book.
The person who wrote the
book is talking to you,
and everybody who ever
read the book in some ways
is in on that conversation.
And everyone that author
ever read to produce the book
is also in on that.
The question, I think,
is one for oral culture,
it was always limited
by physical proximity
to the person who
had the memory.
In artifactual culture,
our access to that culture
was always limited
by physical access
to that physical artifact.
Now, our oral conversation
or our virtual conversation
is limited by our
access to this.
I'm holding up a phone.
And there have been these
wonderful experiments.
I'm sure many of you have read
about the experiment performed,
and the results were what
they called the Google
effects of memory, that people
have an emotional reaction
to being separated from this,
which is neurologically very
similar to the
emotional reaction
they have being separated
from a family member.
If they need a
piece of information
that their mom knows,
and mom's not around,
that's the same
kind of reaction.
So people, I think, are
being able to, in a way, move
to a third kind of
mental instantiation
of human connections in
this very miniature form.
And we know that it's
rewiring the brain, which
is not a bad thing.
It just it's a fact.
It's rewiring, and where
we pay attention to
and how we receive information.
But again, the
question is, how do we
transmit what is
valuable across cultures,
like the oral tradition did,
without the filters that
are yet built in, the filter
either a physical proximity
to the source or
physical proximity
to the artifact itself?
And you have something which
is ubiquitous and everybody
has, how do you learn how to pay
attention to which conversation
to have?
So that's, I think, a challenge.
I mean, I can't quite
conceptualize how that is.
And I hope other people
can conceptualize it,
because it is,
actually, something
that makes us, in a way,
fundamentally different.
And this really is a
very interesting point
of inflection in our time.
I think about the answer
to the general question
that you posed is something
that as an historian,
I can just stand back
and say, well, you
know we're not going to
know this is the answer that
for at least several decades.
And I say that as an
historian because, I mean, I
spend a chapter in the
book talking about one
of the first printed
natives, a man
called Michel de Montaigne, who
invented the personal essay,
for example, a very famous
book that is still in print
and read today and
widely imitated.
But he was among the first
of the print natives.
And what people who grew up with
the manuscript culture assumed
was going to happen
with print was not
at all what actually turned
out to be that the case,
and that what was
native to Montaigne
turned out to be
something completely new.
I mean, they were new writers,
like Montaigne, new genres,
new audiences,
completely new topics,
and also a new-- what can I say?
Engendered the most
amazing kind of curiosity
in people that had never
been awakened before,
because there wasn't access
to this kind of information.
So there's this kind of
feedback loop of providing
the information, and it
engenders a sort of curiosity
that leads to the pursuit
of more information.
One of the things that
I think will evolve,
which is a return
to oral culture,
is that with this sharpening of
our pursuit of curiosity, which
is basically-- there
are no barriers
to the pursuit of our
curiosity if we're always
online-- is that we will
return to this glorious state
of pursuing knowledge basically
for aesthetic reasons.
And when I say aesthetic,
I mean for its own sake,
not because we want
to build a tool
or want to do something
that really makes
a huge difference in the world,
but simply for its own sake
itself.
And that, again, this is
what history tells us.
That, actually, is a question
of profound morality.
And this just gets
back to what Socrates
was saying and Thomas Jefferson
said as well, that pursuit
of knowledge for its own sake
as opposed to just to create
a tool, or even to
create progress,
is the beginning of morality and
the beginning of understanding,
not just how to find the
information that you want
but ultimately to
take responsibility
for how it's used.
And so that's, I think,
a development of that
was well known in oral culture.
There were etiquettes
about that,
mores around responsibility
for information,
what you do with it.
And in the print culture and
now online, it's a free for all.
And that's why I was saying,
it's not really until, I think,
we have the kind of policies
and mutual understandings
about how I treat your
data and you treat my data
that we will actually
see a real flourishing
of that aspect of oral culture,
which is purely fun and gaming.
AUDIENCE: I have a couple
of quick questions.
So one thing is, I
mean, we may find a way
to preserve things and select
which things to preserve.
How do we actually ensure
that what people in-- I
don't know-- 10,000 years
will be able to read that,
understand that?
I mean, you have the
example of Linear B.
There's a lot of preserved
Linear B tablets.
We have no idea what
they're saying to us.
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: Right.
Just as we had no idea what
those cuneiform said until some
really curious people decided
they would figure that one out.
The truth is, we don't know.
And really, this is
one of the models
that we need to shake
off from the print world
and from this world of
well, we put it in print.
We put that book in
storage to keep it safe.
We can read it in 5,000
years or 10,000 years.
No, I think the new model is
that we keep information alive.
And so rather than
thinking about
whether we can read it in
5,000 years or 50 years,
I think we ought to focus on
keeping it alive and readable
five years out, and then
renewing it, doing another five
years.
AUDIENCE: But that's what
they were doing in Alexandria.
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: Yeah,
and Alexandria, I mean,
I'm not sure what
the connection is,
but they never had an
intentional Alexandria
of creating this information
for that long a period of time.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
what I'm saying
is they were trying to preserve
the information that they
had about their
world, the best job.
You may have--
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: Yeah, I know.
You're right.
AUDIENCE: You may
have the intention
to do the best job that you
can, but that doesn't guarantee
that it will actually survive.
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: Oh, no.
Absolutely.
I mean, if the business of
creating knowledge is basically
out of fashion or some
religion or ideology
tells you that
it's not good, when
you force a monoculture
on somebody,
then that knowledge
itself will disappear.
And there is nothing
we can do now
to guarantee that
it won't happen.
But the only thing we
can do is make sure
that it survives to
the next generation,
and that we inculcate
in the generation
the value of keeping it alive.
But no.
No, there's no guarantee.
AUDIENCE: But we do
have many models.
I mean, he mentioned--
the previous questioner
mentioned peer-to-peer, right?
So even if a monoculture appears
in one part of the world,
if you make multiple
copies, one will survive.
But in 10,000 years
time, I mean, who knows?
I mean, there's a
lot of problems.
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: In
theory, multiple copies
keep things safe.
But that's only as long as
people care about the past,
or actually about the future.
AUDIENCE: Right.
That's why we have you here.
And the other
question that I had,
for technology companies
specifically, like the Googles,
the Facebooks, the people
who have lots of information
in, so to speak, walled gardens,
what would be your top three
recommendations?
We talked before this talk about
how I'm doing my backups now
of all sorts of things into
Google Photos, where it doesn't
cost me anything, and I'm
uploading miniDV tapes
from the 2000s.
I mean, would it
be useful for users
to have a specific
archive this button?
A tag, if you will, to tell
everybody else in society,
I think this is
worth preserving?
The Library of
Congress may not agree,
but it is a signal
that an individual,
that a citizen could give,
hey, I think this is worthy.
ABBY SMITH RUMSEY: Yeah,
that is a very good idea,
and it's been
proposed many times
in libraries, who are trying
to figure out what to collect.
I think the Internet Archive
is actually such a thing.
It's practically trivial
to actually upload things
to the Archive.
But more to the
point, or at least
answer the question,
what is it that companies
that hold a lot of information
assets close to the chest,
shall we say?
There are a couple things
that the rest of us
are hoping that you will do.
And it's not just
technology companies.
It's also the military,
which has solved innumerable
digital preservation problems,
which, I have to assume,
they're not sharing.
First of all, make it abundantly
clear to the people who
use your products that-- and
I go into this in the book--
that the services
you provide that are
free at the point of transaction
are actually not free.
And I think many
people know that now,
but I think we all need
to raise our children
and tell each other,
remind each other
that even emails that are
used, Gmail because it's free,
isn't actually free.
I mean, it's not necessarily.
it's not totally
mine to control.
So I do my own backup.
I'm a writer.
I backup every day.
I also backup on lossy
at a second home.
It's also in the
earthquake zone.
And then I keep some
things on the cloud.
But for the things that
are truly important,
I print some things out.
I mean, I think everybody will
have their own way of ensuring
what's valuable for them.
But in terms of the
big companies that
are building this
digital universe,
I've always been convinced
that, like the military, certain
companies like Google and
Apple and Sony Pictures,
they invest a huge
amount of money
in keeping those assets alive,
because they're profitable.
The day that Sony Pictures
decides that these films
or whatever it is
not profitable,
they shouldn't just
unplug the server.
They should actually
hand off those assets,
which are now cultural assets
and not economic assets,
to a not-for-profit or
some organization which
will preserve it for
future generations,
present and future generations.
Those handoffs are
very hard to craft.
Twitter has one with a
the Library of Congress
now, which is quite wonderful.
But I think that Google
and other companies
can be doing far more controlled
experiments in how we actually
identify a block of
cultural information, which
may lose its economic
interest, economic value.
And how do we move that
into the not-for-profit,
the public sector
for its eternal life.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]